he's American literature's Titan of
terror the writer who created some of
the most iconic names in sci-fi in his
46 short years of life HP Lovecraft was
responsible for the alien god Cthulhu
the Necronomicon Book of the Dead and
the haunted town of Arkham where things
always go bump in the night he inspired
everyone from Stephen King to jorge luis
borges to the writers of batman his work
is so penetrated pop-culture that you
can even buy plush toys of his creepiest
monsters yet HP Lovecraft was a man
virtually unknown its lifetime living as
a recluse in Rhode Island's he created a
sprawling fictional universe that fused
traditional horror with cutting-edge
science in new and revolutionary ways
and then he died before more than a
handful of people could read it in the
video today we explore how this virtual
high meadow became sickness isolation
and his own foul prejudices to become
the 20th century's master of horror one
of the recurring themes in Lovecraft's
work is ordinary families hiding dark
secrets in their lineage you don't have
to look too hard to find the inspiration
for this in August the 20th 1890 Howard
Phillips Lovecraft was born into the
stately ancestral home of one of the
oldest families in Providence his
mother's side were wealthy aristocrats
with rumors of inbreeding in their
backgrounds while his father was a
traveling salesman already suffering
from undiagnosed syphilis before young
Howard was even three his dad had a
nervous breakdown brought on by his
disease and he was confined to a lunatic
asylum although the old man lived
another five years Lovecraft he'd never
see him again despite the obvious
setback Lovecraft's mother Sarah tried
to give her child a relatively normal
life the two moved in with her father
the incredibly wealthy gloriously
mustachioed Whipple van Buuren Phillips
it was here that Lovecraft got his first
taste for the uncanny one of Whipple's
party tricks was to invent chilling
ghost stories just off-the-cuff much to
the delight of his grandson still
whiffle couldn't make up for the obvious
hole in young Lovecraft's life from
almost the day that his father collapsed
Lovecraft was paralyzed by psychological
maladies at the age of six
having night terrors of faceless men
that were so acute that he would be left
trembling for days perhaps it's no
surprise that he barely attended school
what that Sara was raising a dumb-dumb
wibbels house was stacked with books
even days he missed school Lovecraft was
reading his way through the Arabian
Nights through Edgar Allan Poe and even
into scientific journals by 1898
Lovecraft was a self-declared atheist
scientist producing his own homemade
magazines on geology strange as his
childhood was it was at least stable but
sadly that's not something that would
last on March the 27th of 1904 Whipple
suffered a massive stroke he died the
next day
immediately Lovecraft's life it was
turned completely upside down it turned
out Whipple's finances had been badly
mismanaged within days of his death
Lovecraft and his mother Sarah were
evicted from the house and forced to
move into a cramped apartment the shock
was so great that Lovecraft by now a boy
of fourteen contemplated drowning
himself in the Barrington river although
it wouldn't come out into the open for a
few more years the day Whipple died is
effectively the day that Sarah and her
son both went mad
in 1908 a Lovecraft would suffer a
catastrophic breakdown largely related
to the tragedy unable to finish high
school Bunn able to attend University he
locked himself away with his mother
cutting off all contact from society
over the next five years the pair's
relationship it turned toxic if we pulls
death had damaged Lovecraft's it had
twisted Sarah she became verbally
abusive towards her teenage son calling
him grotesque and telling him to never
leave her side by 1913 the two were
living as codependent recluses Lovecraft
II never left home before sunset and
spent his endless free time doing
nothing but reading pulp magazines it's
at this time that he seems to have
developed both a crippling social
anxiety and his abnormal fear of the
cold in short love crafts life that was
painfully depressing poor lacking in
friends and goals he was in danger of
simply vanishing from the history books
but his life was about to be saved by
the unlikeliest of Heroes a romance
novelist
you've probably never heard a Fred
Jackson that had he mentioned his name
to HP Lovecraft in 1913 the Rhode
Island's recluse would have vomited up
blood a shameless trash merchants par
excellence
Jackson's insipid tales of cliched loved
stuff the pages of the Argosy a magazine
Lovecraft perhaps somewhat masochistic
Lee often Rhett finally fed up with this
hag Lovecraft did exactly what any angry
weirdo living alone with his mom would
do he totally trolled him through 1913
Lovecraft sent a sea of letters to the
Argosy attacking Jackson's lack of
talent and each time he did it in rhyme
it was a bizarre thing to do it was
almost childish but it was the thing
that actually made Lovecraft's career by
1914 this weird letter writer has
reached the attention of Edward F das
presidents of the United Amateur Press
Association the UA PA intrigues darth
read some of Lovecraft's Andy Jackson
poems apparently he likes lemons
he offered Lovecraft a job and so began
one of the unlikeliest literary careers
in history perhaps flattered by dass's
attention the 24 year old Lovecraft's
took to amateur press work like an
unspeakable sea demon to water
he wrote essays published magazines
composed poems he even finally left his
mother's stifling embrace and made some
friends and good job too because it was
those friends who convinced him to try
his hand a fiction Lovecraft's had
written fiction stories as a child but
never really anything serious until the
summer of 1917 that was when the now 27
year-old Lovecraft sat down and wrote
Dagan the story of a shipwrecked sailor
who finds himself trapped in mysterious
island filled with the ruins of some
hideous civilization
Dagan is a short creepy piece that
already contains the seeds of
Lovecraft's greatest works it's free to
read online by the way advances in the
homework but the important point is that
this is the moment this is the moment
when Lovecraft the weird lonely recluse
vanished and Lovecraft the weird lonely
writer arrived not that this transition
came without tragedy in
19:19 Lovecraft's mother Sarah had a
total breakdown confined to the same
lunatic asylum Osmond iDEN she spent two
more years raving before finally dying
herself in May of 1921 suddenly orphaned
still too strange to fend for himself
Lovecraft was taken in by a snobbish
ance Lillian D Clarke and Annie E
Phillips gam well this would not be a
happy relationship but before we dive
into that it's time we introduced the
last significant character in the life
of HP Lovecraft Sonya haft Greene a
Russian Jew seven years Lovecraft senior
Sonya was a face known on the amateur
press scene independently wealthy from
her successful hat store she bankrolled
several low-budget magazine barely two
weeks after Sarah's death Sonya was
visiting au APA convention in Boston
when she was introduced to the newly
orphaned Lovecraft somehow the two hit
it off what followed wasn't exactly a
Fred Jackson star romance Lovecraft was
so disinterested in sex that Sonya had
to cajole him into making love by giving
him text books on romance to study
perhaps unsurprisingly Pete would later
claim Lovecraft was a virgin when they
met still the two really did like one
another on March the 3rd 1924 they Wed
in a secret ceremony only informing
Lovecraft's disapproving arms by letter
not long after Lovecraft left Rhode
Island's and moved in with Sonya in New
York it was spring 1924 and life was
good
Lovecraft was having his first stories
professionally published in Weird Tales
and Sonja's hat business was booming
things they were finally getting on
track
[Music]
except of course he couldn't last Sonia
was unwell by the end of 1924 her
illness was eating up so much of her
time that the hat shop had gone bust
Lovecraft had meanwhile bungled his one
shot at a stable income by turning down
the opportunity to add a rival pulp
magazine to weird tales come Christmas
of 1924 the two were broke on January
the 1st 1925 Sonia moved alone to
Cleveland to take up a job left behind
in New York Lovecraft rented a tiny
apartment in Brooklyn's notorious Red
Hook it was a mistake that would haunt
him for the rest of his life
Lovecraft hated rhetoric he absolutely
hated it surrounded by immigrants
suddenly alone and broke again he
descended into a twisted bitterness that
found its expression in the worst kind
of racism yes it's time for us to talk
about the demonic elder God in the room
Lovecraft was a bounding racist the sort
of person it's hard to believe exists
outside of daily storm a message wards
in 1912 for example aged 22 had written
a poem
referring to black people as beasts and
semi human figures he was also a raging
anti-semite he once wrote of New York
City the population is a mongrel herd
with repulsive mongoloid Jews in the
visible majority and the coarse faces
and bad manners eventually come to wear
on one so unbearably that one feels like
punching every goddamn bastard in sight
yikes lest we be accused of unfair
treatment we should note here that
Lovecraft's racism was more complex than
it at first appears you probably
remember from t 1 minutes ago that his
wife Sonya was herself Jewish well she
wasn't the only Jewish friend that
Lovecraft hat tablet magazine notes that
the pulp writer Robert Bloch who would
later penned the novel Alfred
Hitchcock's Psycho is based on was a
friend of Lovecraft's and so is the poet
Samuel Loveman Lovecraft then was a man
who was openly racist but in the
abstract sense faced with people he
personally liked he weren't white
Protestants Lovecraft seemed to have no
problems discarding his racial beliefs
not that there were many people
Lovecraft liked in Red Hook though as
1925 dragged on the reclusive writers
feelings towards foreigners turned
into something close to horror the dread
he felt surrounded by a sea of non-white
faces turned into a genuine phobia it's
since been argued that this phobia
influenced Lovecraft's work itself with
his tales of nameless forces and
unknowable aliens it's not too much of a
stretch to think that Lovecraft was
simply channeling his inner feelings
towards New York's multicultural
population if that is the case well at
least we can say that something good
came of his very poisonous thoughts by
early 1926 Lovecraft had had enough he
wrote to his aunts Lillian and Annie
begging them for help the two agreed to
engineer his return to Providence but at
a price
Sonya would not move to Rhode Island and
she would never see her husband again
exhausted desperate to get away from the
city he hated so much
Lovecraft agreed although he still
claimed to love Sonia he moved back to
Providence on April the 17th 1926 and he
would never see his wife again
in summer 1926 the hideous creature rose
out of the waters of the South Pacific a
monster of vaguely anthropoid outline
but with an octopus like head whose face
was a mass of feelers a scaly rubbery
looking body prodigious claws on the
hind and fore feet and long barrow wings
behind the monster towered not just over
all who saw it but over horror fiction
itself it's name was Cthulhu and it was
to become the most importance of all of
Lovecraft's creations the star of a
short story that Call of Cthulhu Cthulhu
was Lovecraft's first creation after
returning Providence an elder God biding
his time in the depths of the sea
waiting with a moment humanity will
awaken him and destroy the world Cthulhu
has gripped our imaginations ever since
there's even a region on Pluto named
after him yes at the moments he first
raised his unspeakable head from the
waves
Cthulhu seemed destined for obscurity
newly arrived back from New York
Lovecraft had little hope for his latest
monster beyond a small paycheck and some
fleeting recognition luckily though his
friends they had other ideas
Ramar we talked about how Lovecraft
finally made some real friends after
joining the UAP a way back in 1914 well
over the years that evolved into quite
the little circle of pen pals among the
number were a robot block of psycho Fame
Robert E Howard the creator of Conan the
Barbarian and writer August Derleth
who's about to become really really
important in about five minutes when
these guys read Cthulhu they went
absolutely nuts
Cthulhu it was something new it
encouraged everyone in Lovecraft circle
to start writing their own tales set in
the same universe over the next decade
the group would build up something
called the Cthulhu Mythos it's the
reason we still remember the character
of Cthulhu today at the same time as
this mythos was growing Lovecraft went
through his most productive streak as a
writer something about moving back to
Rhode Island has energized him in a
handful of years he wrote some of his
greatest hits the color out of space the
case of Charles Dexter Ward's the shadow
over Innsmouth and the mountains of
madness if you're not a Lovecraft fan
just know that this is like the Beatles
knocking out Sergeant Pepper the white
album Yellow Submarine and Abbey Road
one
after the other it was a master working
at his peak conjuring Vista's of
cyclopean alien cities and eldritch
horizon-- like anything readers had ever
experienced before
love graph may have been living in semi
poverty with two domineering aunts and
no access to the woman he loved but it
was clearly doing wonders for his
productivity even the bruising Wall
Street Crash of 1929 failed to dent his
newfound enthusiasm as the nineteen
thirties got underway he was scraping
together enough funds to take long
jaunts along the coast of his beloved
New England but if there's one thing
we've learned about Lovecraft's life so
far it's that all good things must come
to a terrible end and soon enough they
did in 1932 Lovecraft's aunt Lillian
Clarke died despite her overbearing
personality Lovecraft was devastated he
and his surviving Arne's Annie were
forced to move into a tiny apartment it
was the beginning of a long slide into
grinding poverty Lovecraft may have been
writing his greatest work at this point
but his greatest work
it was long complex stuff and it had no
mass appeal what he and then he needed
were short punchy tales that he could
sell regularly not something like the
Antarctic horror of at the mountains of
madness which took five years to find a
buyer
the Lovecraft had too much integrity or
perhaps too much stupidity to lower his
standards he only took on ghost writing
work in order to survive way back in
1924 it ghost written herself a Harry
Houdini and the two had become friends
so maybe this would be just as rewarding
sadly it was not to be the ghost writing
of Lovecraft's final years took up all
of his time and left him drained and as
poor as it ever been he took to eating
tins of expired food in order to survive
and that was only when he could afford
to eat at all perhaps one of the
positive achievements Lovecraft made in
these gloomy years was to keep up his
letter-writing from the days of his
trolley nurses to the Argosy Lovecraft
had composed letters with a commitment
rarely seen before or since
it's estimated he sent a hundred
thousand letters in his lifetime second
only to the great French philosopher
Voltaire by spring 1936 Lovecraft had
almost given up on his fiction his only
story since 90
30:3 had been the shadow out of time now
considered a late classic ins the creepy
that short hunter of the dark so why
this sudden lack of interest in alien
worlds well it may have been because
Lovecraft had found something else to
write about in the cold New England
winter of 1935 to 1936 Lovecraft had
begun documenting an illness that he was
suffering from that he called the grip
this scrip was actually cancer as 1936
wore on it ate away at his intestines
until his insides were riddled with
tumors like the recluse II was Lovecraft
refused to see a doctor
that summer more bad news came Robert E
Howard the Conan writer and friend of
Lovecraft committed suicide by shooting
himself in the head the death of his pen
pal sent Lovecraft spiraling into a
depression from which he never fully
recovered by spring 1937 it was all too
clear that something was deeply wrong
Lovecraft had written nothing but four
poems in over a year he was in constant
agony and consumed by black thoughts
often you had said alone at night in the
cold and gloomy apartments haunting the
darkened room like one of his own
creations on March the 10th 1937 the
pain it finally became too much
Lovecraft checked himself into the Jane
Brown Memorial Hospital but by now the
cancer had gone far too beyond what any
treatment could take care of five days
later on March the 15th 1937 HP
Lovecraft passed away in his last
moments it's possible he wondered what
would become of his work after he died
if he did we can only assume that he
thought his writings scattered across
cheap pulp magazines would soon be
forgotten but he had encountered on
August Derleth
[Music]
rather how we mentioned that August
Derleth was one of Lovecraft's writer
friends and was going to be really
really important to this story at some
point well this is that point after
Lovecraft died delyth decided to give
the old master the literary send-off
that he deserved in August of 1939
Derleth founded Arkham house publishers
specifically to put out hardback
editions of Lovecraft stories The
Outsider and others has appeared the
same year and was resoundingly not a
success its advance orders came to a
mere 150 copies when one wound up at the
New Yorkers officers they gave it a
dreadful review but here's the thing
about Derleth he may have been a hack
writer who utterly failed to grasp what
Lovecraft was trying to do with his
fiction but he was a loyal friend and he
was also a friend who just happened to
have very deep pockets over the next few
years Derleth kept Arkham House afloat
putting out volume after volume of
Lovecraft's tales he even had them
translated into foreign languages this
turned out to be an excellent move over
in post-war France the French
translations of Lovecraft's works became
hugely popular it helped that Paris
intellectuals already considered Edgar
Allan Poe literary Titan and Lovecraft
was clearly Poe's 20th century's
successor
by the 1960s Lovecraft was so popular
abroad that it made financial sense for
Arkin house to re-release his story
stateside the timing simply couldn't
have been better
Lovecraft reappeared on the scene just
as a new wave of films was making horror
popular again Rosemary's Baby Night of
the Living Dead not to mention the first
US release of Britain's Hammer horror
films sparked a surge of interest in
weird fiction legions of people who'd
never read horror or sci-fi flocked to
Lovecraft by the 1970s the gentleman
from Providence a serious fan base what
followed was a dizzying embrace of an
author who'd only ever written for part
magazines in 1974 Batman's writers
borrowed the idea of Arkham Asylum from
Lovecraft in 1977 super fans Stephen
King exploded onto the literary scene
with Cary and spent the rest of his
career encouraging others to read
Lovecraft that same year a group of
American fans cobbled together enough
cash to replace Lovecraft small
tombstone with a gigantic stately one
bearing the legend I
Providence the cult of Lovecraft's like
the cults that gather around the great
Cthulhu and his stories could no longer
be ignored in the years since that myth
of Lovecraft has only grown today's
stories have entered the Canon of
American fiction both Penguin Classics
and library of America of released
volumes people as diverse as Neil Gaiman
Alan Moore and Guillermo de Toro have
been influenced by him he's arguably the
best-known horror writer whose name
isn't anger Allan Poe but perhaps the
best way to explain the enduring appeal
of HP Lovecraft is through the words of
Erica Henderson the Marvel artists
responsible for Squirrel Girl speaking
to the Guardian in 2013 she said
Lovecraft made a world where humans are
alone floating on a rack in a terrifying
larger universe that we cannot possibly
comprehend because our time in it has
been so short and we are so
insignificant compared to the horrors
from the Cthulhu Mythos so much of
modern horror is based on that idea we
wouldn't have Ghostbusters who went for
Lovecraft
and that's the best argument that I can
think of for his work he may have been a
weirdo
he may have held despicable beliefs but
Lovecraft was an artist who would come
to influence the very way that we think
about horror from his twisted mind he
brought us nightmares we'd never even
dreamed of before nightmares that still
haunt us to this very day so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did please do give us a thumbs up
below and don't forget to subscribe also
if you're looking for something else I
got another channel called top 10s we do
top 10 lists we've got authors on there
as well as lots of other people and just
interesting fact so go check that out
you'll find a link to it below as well
as on the screen and as always thank you
for watching